from taco bell to pizza hut we wanted to
find out all the biggest portion size
differences between uk and u.s fast food
this is food wars
taco bell we're talking tacos at the u.s
taco bell you can get an individual hard
shell taco
or
you can get
three
with
a drink i went with medium or you can
get a party pack which is 12. yay get a
load of this it's like i'm presenting a
newborn
[Laughter]
the serving sizes for tacos in the uk
are one individual taco or
two tacos fries and a drink which is a
combo meal this is a u.s beef taco
supreme first thing i'm gonna do is
measure it hang on oh man it's almost
exactly six inches all right let's weigh
new scale
what is it oh over 100 grams this is a
crunchy beef taco supreme in the uk
it measures
exactly five inches across
and it weighs
70 grams
wow that's way heavier
what is up this is a standard burrito in
the uk we've gone for crispy chicken i
also want with chicken
it measures
six and a half inches in length oh you
know what
six and a half inches weighs
about 210 grams
uh 230.
here's our quesadilla it is
yo dude it's a foot 12 inches this is a
uk chicken quesadilla it measures 10
inches in length and it weighs
245 grams yeah about 245
weighs the same
wider
crunchwrap supreme
this is a crunchwrap supreme in the uk
it measures
six inches point to point
and it weighs
about 240 grams what's six cents without
looking it up
does anyone know what a six sided shape
is hey siri
what is a six sided shape
according to giantbomb.com
regular hexagons
hexagons
yo dude
guess how many inches
six babies
that is obviously that's on purpose i
wonder if there's
something about
six sides six inches
if this thing weighs 666 grams i will
never not eat these here we go
[Music]
275
for the hexagon crunchwrap supreme six
sides six inches
at a pizza hut in the u.s the pizza size
that you want to get is often dictated
by the type of crust you want to get for
instance this right here is the smallest
you can get six inches but you only get
it with the pan crust in the uk our
pizzas come in three sizes firstly we
have this small
okay so they didn't actually have a
small pizza when we went because they
said that no one orders them and if they
do they normally just give them mediums
however a small is supposed to be nine
inches across in the u.s at a pizza hut
the only small pizza you can get is one
with gluten-free crust this one here is
10 inches the next size we have in the
uk is the medium pizza
this one is 11 inches across
the large you can also get in the hand
toss the pan or the thin and crispy
crust this one 14 inches
pizza in the uk also offers an
all-in-one pan box meal where you can
get a large pizza of your choice as well
as two sides and two sauces here in the
us you can get two box meal options this
first one is a medium pizza five bread
sticks and some dipping sauce and then
ten cinnamon sticks with dipping icing
and it comes in one box that really
helps when you're eating this in your
car by yourself
not big enough you say don't worry pizza
hut has got you and the family covered
this is the big dinner box
oh
man
look at this dude it's like opening the
suitcase in pulp fiction
this looks awesome you got two pizzas i
got pepperoni and i got sausage 10
cheese sticks and you get an option of
either pasta or chicken wings get real
get wings in the uk we got these ones
from a restaurant and they gave us a
portion of six bbq wings not to be
outdone we went ahead and proved a point
to no one by going just a little bit
further with our wing size options you
can get six you can get 12. you get 18
or 36.
[Music]
lemon pepper nope i don't like that
this is a uk chicken burrito we've also
got some black beans some white rice
some lettuce cheese sour cream guac as
well inside we're going to measure the
length the
i don't want to say good
we're going to measure the length the
girth and the weight of this burrito
so our burrito is seven inches long
i have the same burrito harry has right
here well not the same one the same
order i don't know where the burrito
ends in the tin foil begins so i'm kind
of eyeballing it looks to be about uh
between seven and a quarter and seven
and a half inches
a girth of 10 inches
it has a girth of
i promise i'm a professional it's
circumference girth really going all the
way around almost exactly 10 inches
burrito is a 10 if you're uh thinking
about making it a tux
and finally it weighs
more than this
this isn't even the big boy hey
told you guys to get a new scale we got
a new scale
bear with us
so we're going to weigh this burrito
half at a time to see what the toaster
is
half one 310
and then this one that's okay we'll get
the scraps from the plate
so combined the two halves of our
burrito weighed 597 grams chipotle's
burrito order wade man that's hefty that
is a hefty boy
in the uk we can also get our burritos
in bowl form
this bowl contains the same ingredients
as our burrito but obviously without the
tortilla wrap let's wear and see what it
measures up to
so this one came out to pretty much
exactly 500 grams which even with the
bowl factored in is like 100 grams less
than the burrito so this here is that
same burrito ingredients in bowl form
i'm gonna have to go this way oh wow i'm
really smart wait is it heavier
wow so quickly i'm wrong but there's
more here than it was in the burrito
finally we can get our meals in the form
of a salad now this has all the same
ingredients as our bowl but without the
rice let's weigh it and see how much
difference that makes
strangely enough this cane's are pretty
much exactly 500 grams the same as the
burrito bowl and here is the salad
version of that bowl which was the bowl
version of that burrito
sticking with me so far
being weighed
i do want to point out this does have
white rice on it i mean salad is boring
and disgusting i would never get one in
the uk you can only get one size of
chips on the side and it's roughly
this many
some of these are a little bit fractured
so i will just try and form whole chips
where i
can i'm like the banksy of tortilla
chips thanks you've done it again
29 30 and a half
at a u.s chipotle you have two sizes of
chips
the regular
and
the large regular chips first
it's gonna take forever
all right
a regular bag is roughly 41 chips now
let's count the large
75.76
nearly double for the large bag of chips
at chipotle very nice in the uk we only
get one size of guac on the side it's
supposed to be four ounces we're gonna
measure it to check if that's the case
ours was just shy of four ounces so
pretty much right the guac in the u.s of
course comes in two sizes as well and
i'm gonna weigh them just to make sure
just to keep them honest i don't know
how much the measuring cup is so it
should be over four ounces of anything
3.75
that's including the cup which correct
me if i'm wrong you do not eat
skimping on the guac
don't act like point two five ounces
isn't that much if it's not that much
then put it in there eight oh zeezers
it's a little over seven zoom in on that
i wanna shame these people shame on you
chipotle you're already charging us
extra for it and you're also just not
giving us as much as we pay for tisk
tisk
dunkin donuts in the u.s you get your
donuts in three different sizes i guess
one donut
half a dozen donuts nice
and of course everyone's favorite
dozen donuts
in the uk our donuts also come in three
quantities and shockingly it's the same
as in the states
you can get one donut a half dozen
donuts
or you can be the life of the party
with the full dozen
and it's food wars so you know
we're weighing a doughnut now let's see
how much a glazed doughnut weighs in the
uk
[Music]
ugly doughnut came to pretty much
exactly 50 grams so it looks like the
states are getting a better deal any us
dunkin donuts you can get your munchkins
in four different units of munchkin
[Music]
five munchkins
dude
ten munchkins
not enough
kick it up to 25 munchkins yeah and if
that isn't enough you can get all the
way
to 50 munchkins 50 of these things wow
look at the size of this it's a lot of
munchkins in the uk we also have four
units of munchkin starting with
four
from there we move upwards
to
12 munchkins the next size up from 12
is in a box and the box contains
24 munchkins and finally
our biggest size of munchkins in the uk
it's 50.
that might not make too much sense to
compare just one munchkin in the uk and
the us because i'm sure they're all
slightly different shapes and sizes
however what we could do is measure 24
munchkins here and 24 mentions there and
hope that it provides a kind of overview
of the average weight that sounds about
right
sounds like science to me let's do it
all right
this is 25 so i'm going to take one out
oh
can i do it without skipping
let's go
oh
how is that so good
okay munchkin challenge number one how
many munchkins can i fit in my mouth at
one time
without dying
i'm not ready
can you hurry this up man we got other
stuff done
[Music]
for yes seven you were roughly right but
i feel like i started cheated because i
almost died
in the u.s dunkin donuts our hot coffees
come in four sizes
small in the uk our hot coffees come in
two sizes regular and large
large
and
extra large
the dunkin donuts us website says that
their large hot coffee is 20 ounces got
a measuring cup here let's find out if
that is true now
full disclosure and the car head over
here
had a little bit of a spillage
so i'm gonna give this one we'll say a
two ounce leeway should be 20 ounces
might be 18.
okay that's 16.
four more ounces
give me a break
that's maybe an ounce
16 plus one i think is still 17. there
is no way
there is
this much of coffee in my car seat let's
generously add 2 16 17 18 19. i don't
want to be that generous wait a second i
got an idea 20 ounces so that means i
need four in here correct
okay
that's 20 ounces
i'm gonna settle this right now
okay
there's 16 in a cup
plus four you know what's about to
happen you ready
do
come on now now that all seems very
dramatic so i'm also going to measure
our large coffee
not black coffee did i get that with
milk i'm so stupid i just remembered i
put my milk in the lodge so we're going
to measure anyway and see what happens
looks pretty much exactly 16 ounces
iced coffees in the uk also come in two
sizes regular and large at a dunkin
donuts in the u.s we have three iced
coffee sizes
small
yeah mediums and the large
needs like two ounces of coffee that's
just too much
32 ounces do i have enough for 32 ounces
of 16 and this is
eight no i don't we're also going to
measure our large iced coffee to see
what it comes to
so a large iced coffee in the uk came to
18 ounces since i don't have another 16
ounce cup
i will use this one
right on the 16th
okay
that's 1 16 ounce
oh geez this is exactly 16 ounces here
was this the large
this should be 16 more fluid ounces
[Music]
shameful
absolutely
shameful
there definitely was not this much space
left in the cup 27 and a half fluid
ounces in your 32 ounce large iced
coffee
it's still almost to the i mean our pa
just pointed out that maybe the density
is different right when you put exactly
the most frozen ice maybe
we'll
let's ask someone who's a scientist
not a scientist but that won't change
everything and you guys are still kind
of getting a bit short-changed it's just
because the density of the solid or the
liquid might change the actual amount of
liquid in there is still going to be the
same so it should all balance itself out
eventually
burgers from the uk five guys come in
two sizes five guys in the us also has
two burger sizes firstly we have the
little which is just one patty and the
regular which is
two patties
now our patties are supposed to be
lighter than the us patties and should
weigh 67 grams we're going to weigh one
and find out if that's accurate
so this patty actually weighed 52 grams
which is 15 grams less than what we're
supposed to get
according to the u.s five guys website
they say that one of the patties should
weigh 94 grams or about 3.3 ounces we
will weigh a hamburger patty in the u.s
five guys that's about 52 53 grams
it looks like our patties weigh just
about the same as the ones in the uk
we're not sure if they measure it before
or after cooking maybe it's before and
then some of the liquid leaves as it
cooks but either way
not quite what we're expecting now five
guys in the uk is notorious for
overfilling its fry portions we also get
three sizes little regular and large we
ordered all three and they came in one
bag and here's what we got
little fries
regular fries
large prize
and this is the rest of the bag
now we're not sure which of these fries
belongs to which of these portions so
we're going to try and figure it out in
the us we also have three sizes of fries
at the five guys the small
the regular
the large
and yes
so
many more fries look at that so all in
all
five guys is very generous with the
fries
i mean i guess i'll start by filling
each cup
and then try and portion this into like
vague threes i guess
yes
that sounds right i don't know if it is
but i'm just gonna follow harry's lead
on this one
so this is roughly what we think would
go with each of the portions now in the
uk a regular fries is supposed to weigh
414 grams we're gonna weigh the cup and
then also the extras to see if what you
get really is a bonus or if it actually
all adds up to the supposed total
165.
first we'll do the scale right
so this is supposed to be 411 grams
let's see what we got
what is this 170
woof guys that's not even close so our
regular cup of fryers actually only
contain 165 grams which is less than
half of what you're supposed to get
we're gonna weigh the rest of the fries
to see if that makes up the difference
so even with all the bag fries which we
assigned to the regular portion we're
still only looking at 276 grams which is
well below the portion size you're
supposed to be getting for a regular
excellent idea harry i will do the same
now we are up to
275
still not even supposed to be 4 11.
so it looks like we've been a bit short
changed on the fries because it was all
given to us in one big bag it's hard to
tell which portion came out small so
what we're going to do is add the little
fries to this one get a total figure for
all three portions and then figure out
how much we've been shortchanged overall
so we've done the math and between our
large regular and little fries including
the bag fries we only got 830 grams
however we were supposed to get
1220 grams which means we've been
shortchanged by roughly a third here
frygate 2020.
technically harry this is frygate 2021
check the release schedule
with the rest of the bag fries the large
and the little so they gave us 851
grams of fries total
they're supposed to give us
1225. hey siri
851 is what percentage of 1225.
69
nice
so at least in our case it seems as if
the generosity of five guys has been a
bit overstated maybe they just overfill
smaller containers so you kind of think
you're getting more than you should be
whereas in reality if you measure it all
you're actually maybe getting less
in the uk burgers come in two sizes
single and double and in the us our
shake shack burgers also come in single
or double we're gonna weigh the double
shack burger to find out if it's
actually the same size in the uk as it
is in the us
oh man
ours weighs a lot less significantly
less what's up with that shake shack
in the uk we can only get fries in one
size and this is it in the us we also
have only one size of fries
what i meant to say was let's see how
much they weigh
so our portion of fries came to around
188 grams what
this 188
ours is like a little over 100. like
when i say 105 i might be generous
it's a lot less
so far the fries and the burger have
been significantly
smaller than the uk
i thought we were the ones with the big
portions
drinks from a uk shake shack come in two
sizes regular and large the u.s we also
have only two fountain drink sizes
regular and large we're gonna measure
them to find out how much is actually in
these
so a regular drink from a uk shake shack
has about 400 milliliters in it
oh
why [ __ ] in the big one first
[Music]
little over 16 ounces
it fits that's good
it has gone slightly over the scales i'm
gonna in my infinite wisdom assume
that's around 600 milliliters give or
take a few
so that's 16.
jump to the little guy
huh
six and a half
16 plus six is 24
right
22.
and we'll give it a half so 22 and a
half fluid ounces for large
milkshakes in the uk only come in one
size we're not sure what it is so again
we're going to measure it in the u.s our
shakes also come in one size
i mean this thing might be to the line
16 ounces
uh-oh
got some bad news connor
looks like it's a little under 16 ounces
in the uk our sizes start at small ours
is 9.5 inches across with a surface area
of 71 square inches
our small pizza comes in at 10 inches
which is 78.5 square inches of pizza
next up we have our medium pizza it's
11.5 inches across with a surface area
of 103.8 square inches
our large 14 inches which is
153.9 square inches
finally for some reason we skip extra
large and go straight to extra extra
large this one's 15.5 inches across with
a surface area of 188.7 square inches
we didn't skip the extra large 16 inches
right here that's 201 square izzo
zapizzo our extra large is bigger than
your extra extra large in your face
hairy
in the uk we can get donuts in four
portion sizes
as a single donut
as a three
a dozen
or
maybe the life of the party
with a double dozen
in the u.s you can get your donuts in
single
two if you get it with a coffee combo
three pack
dozen look at these beauties or
two dozen
now technically the double dozen isn't
the biggest thing on the uk menu krispy
kreme in the uk will cater for events
like your weddings or your parties and
they can do something called a donut
wall which contains 216 donuts hanging
on pegs on a wall that's 18 dozen krispy
kreme will also make you something
called the donut tower it looks almost
like a wedding cake and is made of
around
216 donuts you got to give them a heads
up though because i went to the krispy
kreme today and asked for one and they
said no also in the u.s at krispy kreme
you can get mini donuts in 4 or 20. i
have to know
i'm in trouble i don't know if i'm gonna
make it through the shoot counter these
are so good
this right here is a standard usa krispy
kreme classic glazed donut
i want to bite into you so bad
but before that let's weigh it now we're
going to weigh a glazed doughnut in the
uk to see what it comes to
they're so light
in the uk our hot coffee sizes are
regular and large us krispy kreme you
can get your coffee in three sizes small
medium and large and if you're really
thirsty
get yourself a brew box
nice
a large hot coffee in the uk is supposed
to be 16 ounces so we're gonna measure
that to find out if that's true and to
make sure that this reading is
absolutely accurate got a big boy
[Music]
okay
krispy kreme in the u.s and get your
iced coffees in two sizes medium and
large iced coffees in the uk also come
in two sizes regular and large they use
the same cups as the hot coffees they
ditch the plastic ones apparently to cut
down the plastic waste now we're going
to measure our iced coffee black
oh
definitely more coffee
[Music]
in the uk we can get wing portions in
four sizes
eight wings
10 wings
12 wings
or
a flavor craver wing platter
which comes with 24 wings and three dips
u.s stop you can get your wings in
not enough you say i agree wingstop also
does wings in orders of
50
75
and of course
100
chicken
wings i'm in heaven right now bury me in
these wings
i'm going in
i'm gonna do better but we gotta move on
sean evans i'm coming for you buddy
so the portion sizes might be pretty
different but what about the wings
themselves we're gonna weigh 10 plain
wings in the uk and do the same in the
us to see how they match up
so 10 plain wings in the uk came to 290
grams which is an average of 29 grams
per wing
off
way higher dude
360 grams i needed my calculator app to
determine what 360 divided by 10 is and
it is in fact 36 grams wow so our
average is 36 grams per wing here in the
us what about chicken tenders well in
the uk those come in two portion sizes
has a portion of three or
as a portion of five
at a wing step in the u.s you can get
your chicken tenders in orders of four
seven fifteen twenty and thirty
yes
i don't know what maniac
is at a wing stop and gets chicken
tenders instead of
wings i get if you like take your like
10 year old there
let's weigh five chicken tenders here in
the us
so five plane tenders in the uk weighs
230 grams 200 what
way over 300 on this one and we're over
300 and they try to pass this off as a
tender bigger chunks of meat over here
in the u.s bigger tender chunks of meats
what about a side of fries well in the
uk these come in two sizes
regular
and large
and in the u.s our wingstop fries also
come in two sizes
regular
and
large how those look
we're gonna wear them both to see what
they come to
that's not a good look for fries
how do i get this back in
yep
also a brick
also a brick
and the large portion came to 255 grams
a regular is bigger than your large uk
okay
oh lots of fry
400 grams
fountain drinks in the uk come in one
size it's 22 ounces but unfortunately we
weren't able to get one today
wing stop in the u.s you could found
drinks in two sizes
20 ounce
and
32 ounce the wingstop we went to did not
have any 32 ounce cups
dips in the uk only come in one size and
it's regular we're gonna weigh a cup of
ranch to see how much we get
dips in the u.s come in two sizes
regular in this absurd tub look at this
first we're gonna weigh this the
regular
size
now the big boy i i couldn't even guess
how much this container weighs
before i do this
closer to 300 this is heavy
this is like half a bottle of ranch
[Laughter]
bro
it is
440. 440 grams of ranch